there's all these pictures of you really
cool pictures of you on a motorcycle or
on a motorcycle and just yeah a couple
then out you're right and that's totally
illegal yes what you're doing there I
was noticing you don't know you don't
have a helmet do you take chances are
you careful I like to do a ride after
every after every gig like every job
right as actually out here a couple
years ago and rented a bike and got hit
by a damn ambulance you got hit by an
ambulance yeah unfortunately it turned
out actually great think so it's great
if there's an especially there's if it's
ambulance with a lawyer inside it
already you're like wow and the lawyer
yeah no there's a universal law you
don't pass on the right there on a
motorcycle but I was late and I was
going around this thing and there's
parked cars on the side and it just it
gets into me and it's rubbing me it's
pushing me it's forcing you to the Sun
see me to get basically smashed into
these it's these parked cars so I'm kind
of trying to nudge it off and finally it
pulls over I go down they jump out and
they're like do you want us to call you
an ambulance
they're like guys this is some you know
insult to injury here are you kidding me
he's like yeah we can't do anything
because we're involved in a scene of an
accident oh so they're not allowed to
take care of you if they're involved
that's the stupidest thing I've ever
heard up pretty close yeah yeah it was
so once the other ambulance arrived
they let it or not and it smashed into
the first step and I and you were stuck
in the middle pinned in between them
we got a call a third one we're not
technically allowed to get it
you